[Music]
hey everybody its charlie we've all been
talking about the end for a lot of
characters on Game of Thrones a lot of
prophecies especially Maggie the frogs
prophecy in the valonqar about Cersei
but there's some really cool Cersei
backstory when she's thinking to herself
and her POV chapters in the books that
provide even more context and make some
of these moments during season 7 and now
what's coming in season 8 that much more
powerful so if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the Game of Thrones videos we're like
now in the window when we're starting to
see footage between now and the end of
the year so things are really starting
to get exciting again and there's new
giveaway stuff that I'll explain at the
end of the video so we all know Maggie
the frogs prophecy where she goes and
she asks will I marry the prince it's
all about whether or not she's going to
get married to Rhaegar but during these
four crows when Cersei is thinking about
Tommen laughing at all of Marjorie's
attempts to try and win him over you
have to remember that book Tommen is
actually much younger than TV show
Tommen so in the books Margaery had to
try and steal him away with kittens and
sweets things that very little boys
would like so Cersei is thinking to
herself saying Margery's clumsy attempts
at seduction were so obvious as to be
laughable Tommen is too young for kisses
so she gives him kittens Cersei rather
wished that they were not black though
black cat's brought ill luck as regards
little girl discovered in this very
castle talking about the mountain
killing regards children she would have
been my daughter if the Mad King had not
played his cruel jape on father it had
to have been the madness that led Aerys
to refuse Lord Tywin's daughter and take
his son instead whilst marrying his own
son to a feeble Dornish princess with
black eyes in a flat chest you have to
love the shade that Cersei throws at
Elia Martell even after she's dead the
memory of the rejection still rankled
even after all these years many a night
she had watched Prince Rhaegar in the
hall playing his silver string harp with
those long elegant fingers of his had
any man ever been so beautiful he was
more than a man though his blood was the
blood of old Valyria the blood of
dragons and gods when she was just a
little girl her father had promised her
that she would marry Rhaegar she
not been more than six or seven never
speak of a child he had told her smiling
his secret smile that only Circe ever
saw it is true that Tywin Lannister had
smiled at times not until his Grace
agrees to the betrothal it must remain
our secret for now and so it had though
once she had drawn a picture of herself
flying behind Rhaegar on a dragon her
arms wrapped tight about his chest when
Jaime had discovered it she had told him
it was Queen Allison and King Joe Harris
so the funny thing about that is that's
all happening a couple years before this
tourney at Lannisport where she goes to
visit Maggie the frog will I marry the
prince and she gets that big valonqar
prophecy also kind of funny to think of
Cersei as an artist as a child you have
to imagine that by the time she was
sonses age they had probably tried to
force her to start pursuing more
quote/unquote ladylike pursuits the
really important detail in there about
Circe's backstory like the secret wish
she never told anyone is that she wanted
to marry Rhaegar in ride dragons so now
think about that in the context of
what's been happening the last two
seasons with Daenerys coming in with her
prince or her King in the north
riding on dragons we all knew that
Cersei wanted to marry Rhaegar that's
not a big secret the real secret is that
her true childhood dream is that she
would grow up to be doing what Daenerys
is doing right now so you have to
imagine how much more Cersei hates
Daenerys because of what she represents
the stolen dream that should be me in
Rhaegar riding around on that dragon and
she doesn't know anything about the sex
boat or the fact that John is Rae garish
true born heir think about how much more
mad she would get then it would
literally be Daenerys stealing her
secret dream this is something that even
Jamie doesn't know about and the whole
reason why it went down the tubes is
because the Mad King thought that Tywin
was trying to steal the kingdom from him
he secretly coveted Joanna Lannister his
wife even though Tywin had been Area's
hand of the King for more than twenty
years and it had been a very prosperous
time for the kingdom the Mad King like
slowly went mad so eventually just saw
conspiracy all around him so what
happened is is while young ten-year-old
Cersei is talking to Maggie the Frog
here
the prophecy of all prophecies the
entire kingdom all the lords and ladies
are Atlantis port for attorney
celebrating the birth of Daenerys his
older brother Viserys so Rhaegar is
there he's 17 he's a newly minted knight
so you have to imagine that he's about
jon snow's age so like full-blown fully
actualized Rhaegar Targaryen things
haven't gone to [ __ ] yet they're still
heading into the long summer remember
all the children on the show now were
born during the long summer
so everybody's riding really high but
the Mad King is slowly descending into
madness so while she's in the middle of
this POV chapter and feast for crows she
also thinks to herself she was 10 when
she finally saw her prince in the flesh
at the tourney her Lord father had
thrown to welcome King Aerys to the West
viewing stands had been raised beneath
the walls of Lannisport in the cheers of
the small folk had echoed off Casterly
Rock like Rolling Thunder they cheered
father twice as loudly as they cheered
the king the Queen recalled but only
half is loudly as they cheered Prince
Rhaegar 17 and new tonight hood Rhaegar
Targaryen had worn black plate over
golden ring mail when he cantered on to
the lists long streamers of red and gold
and orange soap floated behind his helm
like flames you guys see what Rhaegar
doing there he makes himself look like a
dragon two of her uncle's fill before
his Lance along with a dozen of her
father's finest jousters the flower of
the West by night the Prince played his
silver harp and made her weep when she
had been presented to him Cersei almost
drowned in the depths of his sad purple
eyes he has been wounded she recalled
thinking but I will mend his hurt when
we are Wed next to Rhaegar even her
beautiful Jaime had seemed no more than
a callow boy so the reason why I sir she
visited Maggy the Frog is because she
was so filled with the power of her
dream of marrying Rhaegar riding on
dragons and becoming the queen so that's
what all led to this Maggy the Frog
moment so if there was any question yes
Cersei loves Jaime in his rankled by his
betrayal at the end of season seven but
she didn't love him as much as she
really loved Rhaegar Targaryen so even
though there are a lot of theories the
brand isn't going to tell anyone who Jon
Snow real
is think about what she would do if she
found out now the whole thing I think
with Cersei during season 8 is her
descent into madness like we see in the
books and the reason why that mystery
baby appeared during season 7 is to give
her that one last sliver of hope to hang
on to like this baby is my one chance at
a family
so then Jaime leaves her but she still
has that one thing like the baby the one
that is yet to come so the idea is that
when she loses the baby during season 8
that will be the straw that broke the
Lions back and she will become the
full-blown big bad he was knew she would
be go full Mad Queen burn them all so
that's why I'm really hoping that we see
some cyclical moments like everything
coming back around to Robert's rebellion
but think about that idea of Cersei
dreaming of riding dragons with her
prince and then rewatched this moment in
the dragon pit when Daenerys comes
riding in and remember she doesn't even
know about sex boat or who Jon Snow is
she just knows that he's some handsome
prince from the north and that's about
it
so imagine in her own madness that she
believes Daenerys is trying to steal
everything from her even her secret
dream as a child that she never told
anyone this is actually what's really
cool about revisiting some of these book
moments in the POV chapters they had so
much more context for what's going on
with these character twists and turns
it'll be fun to do this after a winds of
winter comes out and recontextualize
some of the big twists on the show let
me know in the comments though do you
think they're actually going to save
full-blown Mad Cersei losing the baby
for like the final episode or the final
couple of episodes or do you think
they'll do that relatively early like I
said there's a new round of that 4k Game
of Thrones blu-ray giveaway all you have
to do to enter that is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video
congratulations to the winner from my
last big video Daniel Moratti please
email me on the about page of my youtube
channel leave all your requests for new
Game of Thrones videos click here for
the best possible news ever learning
about the early Game of Thrones season 8
release date and click here for my
trailer video for that new Jon Sansa
scene thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight